[Music]
resident evil 3 nemesis takes place the
same time period as Leon and Claire's
journey through Resident Evil 2 just as
the military are attempting to fight a
zombie outbreak Jill Valentine returns
and is making her way through Raccoon
City when she stumbles across spell of
stars member and helicopter pilot
Brad Vickers yeah the same guy who threw
Jill the rocket launcher in the first
game
well Brad is trying to escape a new
enemy who is hunting down stars team
members which means he's coming for you
too
a few moments later Brad meets his
demise and the Nemesis is revealed this
guy is the latest bio-organic weapon
umbrella has sent to eliminate all what
this is to their experiments after
fighting the Nemesis are potentially
running away instead Jill meets umbrella
biohazard countermeasure servicemembers
Carlos Olivera no okay McHale Victor and
lead operative Nicolae who informs Jill
that an evac helicopter can be contacted
from the nearby clock tower so off Jill
trots with Carlos following her lead
Nikolai looks to be doing someone's
group ulis things but before we can do
anything about it
he's presumed dead after a massive
zombie outbreak on the way to the clock
tower Mikhail lays down his life in the
hope of subduing the Nemesis and we are
down to two survivors already Jill and
Carlos reached the clock tower and
called the evac helicopter and the game
ends in happiness No
in swoops our nemesis and ticks down the
helicopter with his rocket launcher and
Jill and Carlos are back to step one
things get even worse for Jill as she is
infected with the t-virus during yet
another scuffle with the nemesis but
don't worry all around good guy Carlos
is Jill back to health by locating a
t-virus vaccine Jill regains
consciousness
and after her power nap is ready to
fight for her life she travels to
Raccoon Park and lo and behold Nikolai
is still alive and reveals his true
orders to gather battle dr2 for
umbrellas New Mutants
after he makes a run for it Jill is left
to battle
another t-virus mutation this time in
millipede form known as the gravedigger
is there going to be a moment of rest by
hell no coughs reveals the city is going
to be hit by nuclear missiles in a
matter of hours the US government
believes nuking Raccoon City will
prevent the T virus from infecting the
whole world this may be the right
decision for Humanity but not for our
beloved Jill Valentine depending on how
you played the game the final battle may
change Nicolai will either initiate a
gunfight and be murdered at the hands of
the nemesis or he will steal the last
helicopter out of Raccoon City this
option reveals two further options
either Nicolae gets away in the
helicopter boasting about the bounty
he's going to claim on Jill's life or my
personal favorite Jill shoots down the
helicopter killing Nikolai but
ultimately condemning her and Carlos to
certain death as that was the last
helicopter out of the place forever the
optimist Jill meets the nemesis one
final time and uses a railgun to
obliterate it and can even throw in a
nano SWAT snigger s one-liner to finish
the deal
[Music]
out of nowhere another helicopter is
coming to rescue Jill and Carlos but who
the heck is it it's only bloody very
bloody Burton the legend himself returns
to save his BFF Jill after the trio
leave Raccoon City is vaporized by
nuclear missiles meaning the t-virus is
finally eradicated or does it in the
final sequence Jill once again vows to
take down umbrella and the game ends
next up in the Resident Evil franchise
is called Veronica so that's it that's
resident evil 3 nemesis in three minutes
if you've enjoyed this please give us a
like and maybe think about subscribing
because we could really use your support
I'm Adam from Playstation grenade I'll
see you next time